a jaime le interesan las condiciones
ambientales y si el tren que él toma va
a salir a tiempo durante un año jaime
registra el clima de cada día si es
soleado nublado lluvioso o nevado así
como si el tren llega a tiempo o se
demora
a continuación se muestra una tabla con
sus resultados estas columnas son a
tiempo demorado y total por ejemplo para
los días soleados tenemos un total de
170 días soleados en ese año de los
cuales 167 días el tren salió a tiempo y
tres días en el que el tren salió
demorado podemos ver esta información
para cada tipo de clima y luego nos
preguntan para esos días los eventos
demorado y nevado son independientes
recuerden que solo podemos encontrar la
probabilidad experimental y siempre
debemos ver las probabilidades
experimentales con cuidado mientras más
experimentos podamos realizar más
probable será que nos aproximemos a la
verdadera probabilidad teórica pero
siempre está la posibilidad de que la
realidad sea diferente o incluso muy
diferente
vamos a usar esta información para
encontrar la probabilidad experimental y
la pregunta clave aquí es cuál es la
probabilidad de que el tren salga de
morado y luego vamos a calcular cuál es
la probabilidad de que el tren salga de
morado dado que está nevando si
conociéramos las probabilidades teóricas
de ambas y éstas fueran iguales si la
probabilidad de que el tren salga de
morado es exactamente igual a la
morado dado que está nevando entonces el
estar de morado o que esté nevando sería
independiente pero si conociéramos las
probabilidades teóricas y la
probabilidad de salir de morado cuando
está nevando fuera diferente de la
probabilidad de salir de morado entonces
no podríamos decir que estas dos son
variables independientes no conocemos
las probabilidades teóricas vamos a
calcular las probabilidades
experimentales y aquí tenemos un buen
número de experimentos por lo que si
estas probabilidades son muy diferentes
confianza en decir que no son
independientes en cambio si son muy
parecidas las probabilidades
experimentales podremos decir que es
difícil que estas dos variables sean
dependientes y nos inclinaremos a decir
que son independientes vamos a calcular
los cuales la probabilidad de que el
tren salga de morado pausa en el vídeo y
traten de calcularlo por su cuenta si lo
vemos desde un punto de vista general
tenemos un total de 365 datos o
experimentos y en estos el tren salió de
morado 35 veces cuál es la probabilidad
de que el tren salga de morado dado que
está nevando pausa en el vídeo y traten
de calcularlo veamos
tenemos un total de 20 días nevados y el
tren salió de morado 12 de esos días
esta probabilidad es 12 entre 20 lo que
nos da 60 o debería decir una
probabilidad de 0.6 de que el tren salga
de morado cuando es un día nevado aunque
claro ésta es una probabilidad
experimental esta probabilidad es mucho
más grande esta de aquí es menor al 10%
es menor que 0.1 podría sacar una
calculadora para encontrar el valor
exacto que ese día aproximadamente 0.09
pero viendo los datos experimentales es
mucho más probable que el tren salga
demorado cuando es un día nevado ya que
una mayor proporción de los días que ha
nevado coincide con que el tren ha
salido demorado al menos en comparación
con los días en general con base en
estos datos y debido a que la
probabilidad de salir demorado cuando
está nevando es mucho más grande que la
probabilidad experimental de salir de
morado en general yo afirmaría que estas
dos variables no son independientes así
que la respuesta para estos días los
eventos de morado y nevado son
independientes
no